[Music]
obviously selena has been very vocal and
candid about her health struggles she
recently had a kidney transplant for you
as her mom what was that like and how
difficult was that for you
that was probably be one of the hardest
things to ever experience and as a
parent and especially when there was
complications and it was just me and her
you know and she had to go in and it was
yeah it was um I was not only carrying
first the weight of the mother but also
I felt the weight for like France yeah
and her mother and her family and you
know I I think I'm banned from Cedars
just because I went to both sides of the
towers who for some reason they were
like in different towers and I was just
like every little thing like I was
monitoring and like yelling and freaking
out but it was um it was pretty deep it
was pretty rough like so
god bless any of the families that have
kids that have ongoing illnesses because
I the strength that those families have
is insane because that was just I mean
she will always have lupus but hopefully
that was a one-time thing for us yeah
when you found out that Francia was a
match I mean what goes through your head
the thing that was interesting is how we
actually met Francia is I recall her she
was one of the first people that was not
part of the channel that introduced
herself to Selena and made her feel
comfortable like the Teen Choice or I
remember the moment I met Francie and I
can't tell you the moment I met a lot of
people right and and so I really - like
literally where it was and and I'm in so
that was just really strange how I think
things aligning she walked up and she
introduced herself she was on the ABC
show
mm-hmm and um and so she was already
establishing and she just walked up to
Selena herself and gave her a hug
made her really welcomed and that
resonated with me because it's such a
tough industry that you don't really get
that a lot
[Music]